[Music]
[Music]
one of the problems of living in new
zealand and attempting to create videos
for games that i enjoy is that most of
the major announcements and content
drops happen at some ungodly time in the
morning so i'm usually only seeing the
tail end of the hype throughout the
community unless i've been made aware
beforehand
today as of writing the script when i
woke up people were still buzzing about
a couple of announcements
one of them being the launch trailer
release for operation motherland
if you haven't seen it i'll have a link
in the description or you could always
look it up yourself
anyway i'd suggest you watch that first
if you'd like to make any sense of this
video
so i won't beat around the bush here
will this update from what we can see in
the trailer have an impact on the
quality of life and break point
i'll be the first to admit other than
jumping in to complete the smaller
events that have popped up i haven't
really put too many hours into the game
outside of the initial campaign
it just didn't maintain my attention for
an open world game although beautiful
and aesthetically pleasing it felt dead
i have no ambition to repeat missions
and outside of these there really isn't
all that much going on out there
especially when compared to wildlands
where there would be truckloads of
civilians mulling about doing their
thing with hostiles dotted throughout
well i feel like this update might be
addressing this
but before i get into that let's talk
about the story as you know this is what
initially drew me to these tom clancy
games
after the events of operation greenstone
where the ghost would go on to take down
walker and the bulk of his wolves nomad
and his team lee varroa having now
completed their mission
however months later the island quickly
became a strategic place for powerful
countries who are looking to get hold of
the technology contained within
seeing this threat the cia has tasked an
old friend of the ghosts karen bowman
with diffusing the potential of this
global crisis
the cia aims to ease global tensions by
giving power on the island to a neutral
force haruhi ito and the outcasts
turning a roar into an autonomous
country
but in order to do this they're going to
need some help so the ghosts have been
sent back to assist the outcasts with
removing the remaining hostile forces on
the island
sentinel and the wolves are still
wreaking havoc but there is another
enemy recently seen on the island that
has also joined the fight
the bodaks
and this time they have brought
helicopters vehicles and greater numbers
so there we have it i especially like
how they've avoided without saying the
events of the smaller operations that
have occurred since greenstone the story
of col d walker really was the best
narrative piece and i'm certainly not
upset that the other ops on aurora are
sort of being ignored at this point
however the biggest question i see being
asked from this trailer is when and how
did nomad and his team leave the island
and i get it they've been stuck there
fighting away with no support because of
the drone swarm stopping anyone from
entering and exiting the island
but i don't really see this as story
breaking
unlike other ludicrous editions i'm
looking at you terminator event there
have been so many situations where the
ghosts have been able to assist various
people with escaping opening up holes in
the drone defense to allow entry or exit
the biggest question i have is why did
the ghosts leave
there was obviously a large enough force
of sentinel and wolves still active
beyond what the outcasts could handle
maybe they were called away for
something more important elsewhere
forgetting that what they were leaving
behind was as powerful as it is
perhaps they thought the outcasts would
be fine but the introduction of the
bodaks tipped them over the edge
i don't know but like i keep saying to
people in the comments hopefully the
motherland update will answer these
questions for us we shall see
anyway for now let's get back to what i
was saying about the liveliness of
aurora
operation motherland is introducing a
new mode to the game called conquest
this is an alternative mode to the
breakpoint story mode where player
actions have consequences on what
happens throughout aurora
basically this is a territory control
type situation where we will be faced
with a number of objectives that we're
familiar with like destroying staff
securing camps stealing things from the
enemy and choosing to extract or
eliminate lieutenants who are dotted
around the map
the outcome of these events will lead to
changes on aurora
taking down enemies will show an
increase in outcast presence in the area
leading to an increase in faction
warfare in the territory
each territory will have different
challenges but based on the strength of
the faction power there will be a change
in checkpoints convoys hostage
situations and patrols
this all sounds eerily similar to what
we have in the division too with control
points and factions taking over
different districts
but at this stage it appears to be a
little more dynamic than the open world
activity in the division
however this is a whole new game mode
anyone familiar with the division will
know how repetitive this can be
capturing everything just for it to flip
back over after a set period of time
i'm hoping motherland will be a bit
different offering more replayability
rather than something that just ends up
feeling like more of a chore after the
first couple of times of doing it
but in saying that it'll still add a
hell of a lot more life to an
environment that has been lacking it
since the beginning
i'm just looking forward to having a
reason to explore the whole map again
again talking to the liveliness of
aurora a larger variety of atmospheric
conditions will be added
with the region being split into five
different zones the weather condition
will also change depending on where you
are including the cloudiness rain fog
conditions and sunniness
but also the environmental effects
including insects fumes grasses and bird
flight have been adjusted
and no this doesn't mean a static
weather system the conditions will vary
day by day for each zone
i like this it's the little things that
make a big difference to me
obviously we'll also be seeing a large
range of bug fixes throughout the game
as well as a number of well overdue
quality of life improvements
i'll have a link to this list in the
description
last but certainly not least the bodaks
i'm actually disappointed with myself
that i haven't made a video on these
guys they're certainly one of the more
interesting factions of the ghost recon
universe
maybe i'll get onto that soon
like i said earlier they're back on
aurora
allied to sentinel and the wolves
they'll be the largest challenge going
forward
they'll be arriving on narosh shores
sporting five different archetypes
troopers the standard bodak soldier
tacticians who will call for backup
oppressors heavily armoured rushes
dreadnoughts armed with rocket launchers
and seekers who will use rifles and
optical camouflage
also with the introduction of the bodak
we'll be seeing a large influx of new
russian weapons and vehicle skins as
well as a number of new items in maria's
shop
motherland appears to be breakpoint's
biggest update yet
do i think it will be game changing
it certainly looks promising i'm
cautiously optimistic
i'll hold my final judgment until i've
actually been able to sit down and play
through it properly but i'm excited at
the potential
at the very least i think this is a very
good start and i hope that they continue
to build on the game with initiatives
like this
in the meantime i'm super rusty so i
think i'll jump in and dust off the
characters in preparation for the
release
thanks for watching and i'll catch in
the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]